hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein türkisches rezept und
zwar mache ich patíz mahnte das heißt
auf deutsch eigentlich kartoffel
maultaschen sie kennt ihr vielleicht
alle mann sind diese kleinen maultaschen
die türkischen die habe ich auch mal als
rolle gemacht und alles offen also
auslaufmodell
und im prinzip haben diese kartoffel man
sei eigentlich nicht mit denen zu tun
aber nennt trotzdem sorgen
das ist jetzt ein klar ein teig den mal
aus kartoffeln zubereitet die vorher
abgekocht werden
und dieses gericht wird dann später
entweder warm oder kalt serviert ich
werds kalt servieren
man kann entweder als vorspeise reichen
oder auch als komplette hauptmahlzeit
wenn man eben genug davon auf dem teller
macht ich zeige euch eben mal kurz die
zutaten für ein kilo mehlig kochende
kartoffeln einen halben wurden peter sie
hier etwas pfeffer muskat 1 esslöffel
butter einen teelöffel salz eine
telefonzelle flocken für die joghurt
soße nämlich 500 gramm joghurt das ist
ein naturjoghurt mit zehn prozent fett
eine knoblauchzehe etwas schnittlauch
und natürlich auch salz und pfeffer und
dann noch für die tomatensoße zwei
esslöffel butter und ein essen für
tomatenmark jetzt werde ich zuerst
einmal die kartoffel nehmen und im
wasser abkochen und zwar gebe ich dir
jetzt hier direkt in einen großen topf
und schalt den wert auf höchste stufe
deckt den deckel zu und lässt man die
kartoffeln kochen bis sie weich sind es
dauert jetzt zwischen 20 und 30 minuten
je nachdem wie groß die kartoffeln sind
und ihr erkennt daran ob die kartoffeln
gar sind mit einer gabel rein steckt und
sie eben weich sind
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
gleich um den joghurt herzustellen
dafür nehme ich jetzt den joghurt und er
hat zehn prozent fettanteil das ist ein
richtig schöner cremiger joghurt und es
mag ich auch sehr gerne
natürlich könnt ihr auch einen joghurt
mit 3,5 prozent nehmen auch dann nicht
nur verschieden kriege ich nehme ich die
knoblauchzehe die kann natürlich auch
weggelassen werden aber sie gibt dem
gericht schon so den guten geschmack und
die reibereien rein
dann kommt auch pfeffer mit rein den mag
ich immer gerne frisch weil er viel
besser schmeckt und noch einen halben
teelöffel salz oder eben nach geschmack
und das verriet jetzt schon mal
miteinander ganz kurz zur seite stellen
und auch den schnittlauch fein hacken
den schnittlauch gebe ich jetzt mit rein
aber ein bisschen was hebe ich mir auf
für die dekoration bei dem gebiet
komplett mit den anderen hole ich mir da
noch frisch von der tage das jetzt kurz
verrührt und dann kommt es in den
kühlschrank dafür denke ich jetzt kurz
ab und wahrte so lange bis die
kartoffeln fertig sind und dann geht es
gleich weiter
die kartoffeln sind gekocht und ich habe
es jetzt auch bereits geschickt und kurz
abkühlen lassen
jetzt darf ich sie könnte aber übrigens
auch mit den händen machen und da gehe
ich jetzt auch die butter mit rein dann
könnt ihr nämlich noch schmelzen
wir kommen da jetzt noch die gewürze mit
salz und chili natürlich könnt ihr
chillida zu geben
aber wenn es nicht so schaffen es nicht
aber rot das paprikapulver wird zum
beispiel aufgeben dann im reifen edelsüß
etwas muskatnuss und pfeffer
und jetzt nämlich die petersilie und
hacke die ganz fein und die kommt dann
auch mittragen
die masse ist fertig und sie müsste
jetzt an der stelle abschmecken ob sie
genug leidet hat und pfeffer und wenn
sie gut ist können wir sie direkt
weiterverarbeiten
ich nehme dazu jetzt einen ice
portionierer denn dann habe ich immer
gleich große bändchen bis nehmen die
rebellen in die hand und formt sie und
dann kommt mit dem daumen so ein kleiner
also eine kleine öffnung ein dann ist es
wie so ein kleines schälchen
die kartoffelschalen sind jetzt fertig
und normalerweise kommt als butter
joghurt drauf und die tomatensoße ich
habe jetzt aber noch dazu entschieden
dass ich so etwas auf people und war
nämlich jetzt nur eine zucchini da las
jetzt die schale dran und hobel die
jetzt ganz fein
die wird dann frittiert und die funde
noch mal ganz oben drauf
70 etwas sonnenblumenöl erhitzt und da
kommen jetzt die kniescheiben mit rein
werden frittiert bis sie knusprig sind
und dann nehme ich sehr aus und legt sie
direkt auf küchenpapier abtropfen können
und die zwischenzeit werde ich jetzt
gleich nutzen um die kartoffel körbchen
mit dem joghurt zu befüllen
die chips sind jetzt fertig und die last
etwas abkühlen da werden sie nämlich
schön knusprig jetzt muss ich nur noch
die soße herstellt dafür nämlich jetzt
die butter und das tomatenmark und geht
erst mal die butter in einen kleinen
topf und sobald sie geschmolzen ist
kommt das tomatenmark mit dazu und es
ist sowas richtig typisch türkisch ist
diese butter mit dem tomatenmark oder
man macht auch ganz gerne butter mit
paprikapulver also kann man auch hier
das so gut reichen
ich mag beides super das tomatenmark
hätte zum bitte mit angebraten dann
sitzt all unternehmens auch gleich
hunderte mit uns verbringen
jetzt kann ich die kartoffel teilten
servieren jetzt kommt immer so ein
bisschen was von der tomatensauce mit
drauf
so wird dieses rezept eigentlich
original aber bei mir kommt da jetzt
noch die zucchini scheibe mit drauf die
sehr schön knusprig deswegen kann man
sie reinstecken und falls ihr noch ein
bisschen mehr krampf wollt könnt ihr zum
beispiel solche gerösteten brotwürfel
mit reinstecken
da hat man nämlich auch noch so ein
bisschen bis mit drin das wollte ich
eigentlich vorher reinstecken jetzt habe
ich schon wie tomaten sauce mit drauf
aber am besten macht ihr das dann wenn
die thoma also noch nicht drauf ist
ich bin jetzt fertig und die kartoffel
mahnte kann ich jetzt so servieren
man kann sie jetzt auch noch im
kühlschrank lagern da würde ich sie aber
abdecken damit diese knoblauchduft sich
nicht im kühlschrank verbreitet und man
kann sie jetzt wie gesagt als vorspeise
servieren man kann sie gut zum kalten
buffet vorbereiten oder auch als
hauptspeise und bei der hauptspeise
würde ich sie aber noch mit mehr joghurt
servieren also dass man sich dann ein
bisserl was drüber löffeln kann und vom
geschmack her müsst euch jetzt
vorstellen die mich davon probieren aber
die sind so dass dieser kartoffel
schicht eben sehr cremig ist und sehr
weich aber auch sehr aromatisch durch
die petersilie und an der darf man
übrigens nicht sparen und diese joghurt
gleich das ganze dann so ein bisschen
aus macht das ganze frisch und locker
auf und der klecks tomatenmark finde ich
also diese tomatensoße passt sich
hervorragend mit dazu und ja ich finde
somit den zucchini chips auch wirklich
sehr hübsch und falls er die jetzt name
haben wollt geht auf zehn.de da steht
noch mal das rezept für euch und ja ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und sich zum nächsten mal
tschüss